اندلعت سلسله مواجهات خلال الايام الماضيه
بين الامن التونسي ومجموعات سلفيه كان
اخرها في منوبه بعدها قرر الرئيس التونسي
تمديد العمل بحاله الطوارئ في البلاد لمده
ثلاثه
[موسيقى]
اشهر
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش من زاويتين كيف
يبدو المشهد التونسي بشكل عام في ظل
التطورات الامنيه الاخيره خاصه مع
السلفيين وهل
سيثرون
[موسيقى]
السلام
عليكم اسئله كثيره مطروحه في الشارع
التونسي بشان الوضع الامني في البلاد خاصه
بعد تعدد المواجهات بين الامن
والسلفيين اطراف عده تحمل هؤلاء السلفيين
المسؤوليه عن اخطر الحوادث في البلاد منها
الهجوم على السفاره الامريكيه في سبتمبر
ايلول الماضي بالاضافه الى حوادث متفرقه
كان اخرها في منوبه في ضواحي العاصمه
بالتزامن مع ذلك تطرح اسئله ايضا عن
العمليه السياسيه في البلاد التي تقترب من
وضع دستورها جديد وهل من علاقه بين
التصعيد الامني في الشارع والخلافات
السياسيه بين
النخبه ثلاثه شهور اخرى طوارئ في تونس
قرار اتخذه رئيس الجمهوريه منصف المرزوق
يدل على ان سفينه فاتيحه الثورات العربيه
لم تصل بعد الى شاطئ الامان كثيره هي
الدلائل التي تثبت ذلك اخرها احداث عنف
شهدها حي خالد بن الوليد في منطقه دوار
هيشر بضواحي العاصمه مواجهات قيل انها
اندلعت بين سلفيين وباعه خمور انتهت الى
اشتباك بين السلفيين وعدد من عناصر الدرك
الوطني اسفر عن سقوط قتيلين واصابه اخرين
بجروح متفاوته الخطوره بينهم عناصر من
الدرك تكفلت التحقيقات بالبحث في حقيقه
ملابسات تصعيد امني وضعه المتابعون في
خانه العلاقات المتقلبه بين الحكومه التي
ت هيم عليها حركه النهضه والسلفيين الذين
تعتبرهم المعارضه العلمانيه على وجه
الخصوص خطرا داهما يتهدد امن البلاد ليس
السلفيون وحدهم من يشغل بال الدوله
والمجتمع في تونس ما بعد الثوره فالحديث
يتجدد بين حين واخر عن اياد خفيه تربك
الاوضاع وتدفع بها نحو مزيد من الانفلات
السياسي والامني دون ان تخدم اي جهه رسميه
او غير رسميه على كشف ادله تثبت هذه ال
فرضيه المحامي محمد الشريف جبالي فعلها
منذ ان اماط اللثام امام الحكومه وعامه
التونسيين عن ادله قال انها دامغه تثبت من
وجهه نظره تورت رجل الاعمال المثير للجدل
كمال لطيف في مؤامره نفذت وما تزال تخطط
للمس من الامن القومي التونسي سعيا
بالتنسيق مع شخصيات عامه معروفه لقلب
الاوضاع وتغيير موازين القوى التي افرزتها
انتخابات المجلس التاسيسي ليست المره
الاولى التي تطول فيها الشبهات الطيف
الصديق المقرب من الرئيس المخلوع زين
العابدين بن علي لفتره طويله المشهور عنه
نفوذه الواسع وعلاقاته المتشعبه في الداخل
والخارج وهي العلاقات التي لم ينفيها
الطيف وانما درج في المقابل على نفي
التورت في اي تامر على تونس ومن يحكمها
هذه الايام بلاد استغرق نخبها السياسيه
نقاش حاد مؤخرا محوره توطئه الدستور
الجديد على مسافه في نظر منتقديها من واقع
اقتصادي صعب اثقل كاهل الفئات الفقيره
اكثر من
غيرها ومعنا في هذه الحلقه من تونس الكاتب
والاكاديمي محمد الحداد ومن باريس محمد
هنيد استاذ العلاقات الدوليه بجماعه
السربون اهلا بضيفنا نبدا من تونس وسيد
الحداد ما هي ابرز ملامح الصوره الان في
تونس مع تشعب هذه المواجهه بين السلطات
والتيار السلفي في تونس
شكرا والله ما يحصل او في تونس هناك اليوم
يعني تمديد حاله الطوارئ ولكن يمكن ان
نؤكد لك ان هذا الاجراء اصبح اجراء
روتينيا وان اغلب التونسيين يعني ربما لم
يهتموا به بالمقابل هناك اهتمام بما وقع
في را حيه منوبه من مواجهات بين مجموعات
تحسب على السلفيه وبين قوات الدرك
وهذا الامر يحير التونسيين اولا لانه هناك
استعمال عنف وهناك قتل وثانيا لان هناك
غموض حول الاطراف وحول الدوافع وحول
النوايا وهناك كثير من التشويش على
المعلومات في هذا المجال كما في مجالات
اخرى واعتقد ان الحكومه قد تاخرت
بتقديم المعلومات الدقيقه فيما يتعلق بهذا
الملف الذي يسمى
عامه الملف السلفيه مع العلم ان كلمه
سلفيه كلمه واسعه ويمكن ان تشمل اشياء
كثيره جدا وهناك طبعا كثير من السلفين لا
علاقه لهم لا بالعنف ولا بكل هذه الامور
هذه تسميه واسعه جدا تطلق بطريقه يعني لا
يستطيع معه المواطن التونسي ان يفهم
بالضبط ماذا يحصل وما هي الدوافع وما هي
الجهات المحركه وما هي المسؤوليات في هذه
الاحداث لكن هناك لا شك حاله من الرعب في
هذه المناطق التي هي مناطق فقيره جدا
ومناطق فيها مشاكل اجتماعيه كبرى ومناطق
لم يتحسن
وضعها بعد الثوره بل ربما ازداد سوءا
ولهذا فان هذ هذه الظواهر مرتبطه ايضا
بالفقر وببؤس
وبشعور شريحه من المجتمع انها لم تستفد
الى حد الان من الثوره وربما هذه الشريحه
تعتبر انها ساهمت في الثوره وان كان لها
دور في هذه الثوره ولكن لما تستفد منها
اشرت اشرت سيد حداد اسمح لي اشرت سيد حداد
الى ان هناك حاله من الرعب في في بعض
المناطق وهنا اسال السيد هني في في باريس
ام يعني حتى ان هناك تحقيقات في الصحافه
التونسيه جريده لابريس الحكوميه العريقه
مثلا اشارت الى وجود مناطق تقريبا عمليا
خارج القانون مع تجميع لاسلحه بيضاء في
المساجد ودعوات في المساجد ومن على
المنابر وعلى الماذن ل الجهاد والتصادم مع
مع القوات الامن هنا اسالك سيد هنيد هناك
وجهه نظر في تونس تقول بان الحكومه تاخرت
كثيرا حتى استطاعت ان ان ان ت دخل في
مواجهه مع هذا
التيار وان ما وصلنا اليه هو نتيجه ما وصف
بتسامح او مجامله لهذا التيار هل تعتقد
بان الصوره بهذا
الشكل اهلا استاذ محمد وشكرا لك على
الدعوه ومرحبا بضيفك الكريم ومشاهدي
الكرام المشهد شديد التركيز
و عناصر كثيره فيه ما ذكرته سيدي الكريم
من ان هناك بؤرا موجوده في تونس اليوم
واصبحت تقريبا خارجه على القانون وهي
ظاهره تفسر
تقريبا ازمه النخب اليوم النخب الحاكمه
والنخب المعارضه كل هته النخب اليوم التي
كنا نعتقدها جزءا من الحل اصبحت اليوم جزء
من
المشكله يعني المشهد في تونس تقريبا كنا
ننتظر ان تحرر النخب وتساهم في تحرير
الشعب قام الشعب تحرير هته النخب اليوم
هناك حالات انفلات هته الحالات يقودها
اساسا مواعيد انتخابيه يعني الجميع ينتظر
مواعيد انتخابيه السلطه من هم في السلطه
لا يستطيعون تطبيق القانون بصرامه لانه قد
يقضي على بعض المطامح الانتخابيه القادمه
المعارضه تستفيد بعناصرها المتحركه
والثابته في تاجيج الوضع لانه يخدم
مصالحها دخلت على الخط اطراف اجنبيه تحرك
عناصرها الداخليه و وتحاول ان تبث الفوضى
لكي نعود الى ما قبل 17 ديسمبر والمشهد في
تونس كما ذكر ضيفك الكريم من تونس معقد
خاصه المناطق التي ذكرت انه يسود فيها
الرعب هي مناطق فقيره اساسيا يعني المكان
بمحتوياته بمكوناته يكشف حجم الظاهره
ويكشف لماذا اغلب الشباب يرتد الى ظواهر
مثل الظاهره السلفيه او غيرها من الظواهر
التي يمكن ان تلبي رغبات لم يجدها في
واقعه ولكن هل هل هناك سيد حداد من يتحمل
المسؤوليه في هذا الوضع لان هذا التيار
السلفي كان مقموع بالكامل ايام بن علي كان
في السجون او كان ساكتا يفترض انه بعد
ثوره توفرت فيها حريات ان يعبر عن نفسه
كاي تيار اخر دون ان يصطدم بالضروره مع
الدوله وان يلجا الى العنف ما الذي جعله
يصل الى هذه المرح المرحله
بتقديرك عندما قلت منذ قليل ان الحكومه قد
تاخرت لم اكن اقصد انها تاخرت فقط بالرد
الامني هي تاخرت في محاوله تحليل هذه
الظاهره وفي فهمها وفي التعامل معها
تعاملا سليما يعني هؤلاء اولا انا اعتقد
انه لم يحصل حوار حقيقي معهم ما حصل هو
حوار حزبي بين حركه النهضه وهؤلاء وكان
لغايات حزبيه لفائده حركه النهضه ول يحصل
حوار وطني وانا كنت قد دعوت سابقا في تونس
الى حوار وطني مع هؤلاء حتى يفهم الناس من
هم هؤلاء ويفهم هؤلاء ايضا ما هي الحدود
الموضوعه امامهم مثل ما قلت ان هناك اليوم
حريات وبالتالي الوضع قد تغير في حين ان
بعض تصرفات هذه المجموعات لم تتغير هي ما
زالت تتعامل وكاننا ما زلنا في فتره
الاستبداد وكاننا ما زلنا في فتره بن علي
وك حتى المصطلحات المستعمله الطاغوت وغير
ذلك تظل مستعمله الى اليوم مع ان الحكومه
هي حكومه منتخبه وشرعيه الى غير ذلك كان
ينبغي ان يوجد حوار وطني شفاف واسع اولا
حتى يستطيع التونسيون ان يفهموا هذه
الظاهره التي هي بالنسبه الى تونس ظاهره
جديده حتى وان كانوا هم موجودين في عد بن
علي فكما ذكرت كانوا مقموع وليس هناك
اخبار حولهم والمواطن العادي يعني ممكن
مختص والصحفيين يعرفون ولكن المواطن
العادي لا يعرف شيئا ولهذا هناك اليوم نوع
من الخوف لان المواطن العادي لا يعرف هذه
المجموعات ولا يعرف ما هي الدوافع ولا
يعرف ما هي الافكار نعم سي حدا المواط
المواطن ايضا ربما ربما لا يعرف ولكن ايضا
سيد حداد المواطن مستغرب عندما تتابع
القنوات التلفزيونيه التونسيه الكل يقول
بانه لا يفهم لماذا وزاره الداخليه وعلى
راسها احد قيادات النهضه سيد علي العريض
تبدو وكانها لم تحسم امرها بعد في ان تاخذ
الامور بجديه
و بصرامه امنيه مهنيه هل تعتقد بان كما
تقول المعارضه على الاقل بان وجود شخصيه
حزبيه نهضوي على راس وزاره الداخليه لعب
دورا في تعفين بين قوسين هذه
الظاهره والله شوف هو عندما ترى انت
المواقع التابعه لحركه الن نهضه ترى انه
في كثير من هذه المواقع هناك شعار كان
مطروحا منذ بدايه الثوره يقول النهضه
والتحرير والسلفيه جميعا ضد العلمانيه
ولهذا هناك واضح ان هناك شريحه لا ادري ما
هو حجمها داخل النهضه وداخل الاوساط
القريبه من النهضه التي تؤمن بما يسمى
بوحده العمل الاسلامي وتؤمن بانه ينبغي ان
تكون هناك جبهه واحده ما بين هؤلاء ولذلك
لذلك انا افهم ان وزير الداخليه الذي هو
من
النهضه يعني حركته ستكون صعبه اذا كان
هناك اناس في حزبه يرون الامر بهذه
الطريقه ولكن مره اخرى انا لست من دعاه
الحلول الامنيه انا اعتقد انه يمكن اذا
وضعنا الحوار ليس بين حركه النهضه
والسلفيين ولكن بين مجموع شعب التونسي او
يعني في المجتمع التونسي والسلفيين وعندما
يصبح الحوار شفافا وبعيدا عن
استخدامات الممكنه للسلفيين سواء من هذا
الطرف او من ذاك انذاك يستطيع اعتقد ان
نصل الى نتائج افضل الى حد الان ن ن نعم
خاصه خاصه وان خاصه وان الكل وهنا اسمح لي
بالانتقال الى سيد هنيد خاصه وان الكل
يجمع على ان التيار السلفي اولا ليس واحدا
هناك العنيف وهناك غير العنيف وهناك من
يقول بان كلمه السلفيه عامه وهناك حتى بعض
اصحاب السوابق وبعض المجرمين وحتى بعض
التجار الممنوعات دخلوا هذا هذا التيار
حتى يستطيع ربما لمار اخرى هل تعتقد بان
الظاهره بمثل هذا التعقيد سيد هنيد
اي نعم استاذ محمد هي ايضا اكثر حتى
تعقيدا من ذلك يعني هناك ما ذكرته سيدي
الكريم التوظيف يعني المساله ليست في
الظاهره الظاهره يمكن فهمها المشكل اساسا
في التوظيف هناك عناصر في الداخل وفي
الخارج تستطيع ان توظف هته الجماعات
المتحركه تستطيع ان تختر كما اخترقت
جماعات اخرى تستطيع ان تلبي رغبات لا يمكن
لها ان ان تقوم بها في المجتمع هذا من
ناحيه هذا من ناحيه السلفيين من ناحيه
اخرى هناك هذا التردد هذا البطء الغير
مبرر بالنسبه لوزاره الداخليه وغيرها من
السلط التي تملك اليوم السلطه وتملك قدره
التنفيذ في تونس هناك حسابات انتخابيه
سابقه لاوانها النوايا لا تفيد في هذه
المرحله لابد اولا بالنسبه ذكر ضيفك
الكريم انه انا ضد الحلول الامنيه لكن لا
بد من علويه القانون لابد من تطبيق
القانون لانه لا يمكن ان تعم الفوضى
لاهداف عناصر خارجيه هذا من ناحيه من
ناحيه السلفيين المساجد ان المساجد لله
فلا تدعوا مع الله احد يعني المساجد هي
فقط للصلاه والعباده وليست للتوظيف
السياسي هناك عناصر تريد الدخول على داخل
الظاهره السلفيه لكن اعتقد ان الحل هو
اساسا الحل تربوي حل وفاق وطني وما ذكرته
استاذ محمد من التوظيف الاعلامي خاصه
واذكر لك ان ما يسميه التونسيون تردد
تندرا واستحقاق باعلام العار الوطني
والحكومي يساهم في تضخيم هذه الظاهره
لدينا من ناحيه تكبير لظواهر صغيره وتصغير
لظواهر بارزه هذا التوظيف لا نعرف لمصلحه
من يخدم ليس هناك حوار وطني بين النخاب ال
هناك غياب كبير للبدائل هذا الغياب الكبير
للبدائل على مستوى الواقع وعلى مستوى
النظريه يسمح لظواهر مرضيه ولعنا اسر
خارجيه بالدخول على الخط وبيعني وقدم
الربيع العربي في مهده
تونس والوضع ربما يزداد سو لان هناك
استحقاقات هناك دستور جديد البلاد هناك
انتخابات يفترض ان ان تجري في وسط هذا
العام المقبل لنا عوده الى التداعيات
السياسيه للوضع الامني في تونس بعد فاصل
نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها الوضع الامني
والسياسي في تونس خاصه مع هذه المصادمات
بين سلطات الامن
والسلفيين سيد محمد الحداد هناك بعض
التساؤلات الحائره عما اذا كانت هناك بعض
الاطراف ربما في تونس تحرك هذه المصادمات
خاصه عندما تتزامن مع تسريبات هنا وهناك
تسريبات ل مكالمات هاتفيه لجلسه بين السيد
باجي قائد سبسي والسيد الجبالي لاشياء
تتعلق
ب محاوله او ما قيل عن انها محاوله
لتامر على امن الدوله هناك جو امني وسياسي
غير صحي هل هناك ربما البعض من مصلحته ان
ان يعكر هذه
الاجواء بالنسبه لمساله التامر على امن
الدوله اعتقد انها مجرد فقاعه
وسيقع تجاوزها بعد ايام وقد استعملت هذه
الفقاعه اكثر من مره اما وجود اطراف تريد
ان تشوش على مساله الدستور فهذا اعتقد انه
موجود هناك اطراف عديده هي في موقع
الاقليه وهي اما انها لا تعترف
بالانتخابات او انها تعرف ان حظوظها في
الانتخابات ليست حظوظا مهمه وهي تريد فعلا
ان تعطل مسار كتابه الدستور وتريد ان تجعل
المناخ مشحونا بما لا يمكن من مناقشه
عميقه لهذا الدستور واذا لم يناقش الدستور
مناقشه عميقه فيعني ذلك انه فيما بعد سيقع
الطعن فيه وسيصبح وكانه دستور طرف معين
دون طرف اخر وبالتالي سنستمر في حاله يعني
لا تح يحمد عقباها ولهذا اعتقد انه فعلا
هناك اطراف عديده من موقع انها اقليه
تتحرك وليس بالضروره لانها قويه وقادره ان
تغير الاشياء يعني هذه الاقليه تقصد يعني
عفوا هذه الاقليه تقصد بها المعارضه
الموجوده الان
في مواجهه الح لا لا ليست المعارضه لا
ليست المعارضه المؤسسيه يعني الموجوده في
الاحزاب فهذه المعارضه تؤمن باللعبه
الديمقراطيه وهي مستعده لخوض الانتخابات
لكن هناك مجموعات صغيره يعني في تونس هناك
فسي فساه معقده جدا وهناك مجموعات صغيره
تنتمي الى الاقصى اقصى اليسار او اقصى
اليمين وغير ذلك هي تعرف ان ليس لها حظوظ
حقيقيه اذا ما استقرت الاوضاع واذا ما
اصبحت هناك انتخابات واذا ما اصبح الامر
عادي يعني كما هو في البلدان العاديه
الديمقراطيه هي تستفيد يعني من الوضع
الحالي ولذلك من صالحها ان يستمر هذا
الوضع اكثر ما يكون وان يحصل هذا التشويش
حتى تتاخر عمليه الدستور اكثر ما يمكن
وبالتالي تتاخر الانتخابات القادمه التي
لا يمكن طبعا ان تحصل الا بعد انتهاء
الدستور نعم اشرت الى ان الدستور يحتاج
الى نقاشات معمقه وفي هذه الحاله سييد
هنيد كيف يمكن لهذا الدستور ان يشهد
نقاشات بهذا العمق وهناك وضع امني مطرب
وهناك محاوله ل كما يعتقد البعض
لشيطنة
نعم استاذ محمد يعني اعتقد من ناحيه ان
القول بان هناك من يريد ان
يؤخر مساله الانتخابات ليست في صالحه لانه
حتى لو اخر ذلك الى مرحله يعني الى سنتين
ستبقى نسبه الاقليه وحظوظ فوزه في
الانتخابات ضعيفه جدا هذه من النقطه يعني
الجماعه يبحثون عن نسف العمليه السياسيه
مطلقا يعني بحثهم استاصال وليس جزئي
للتحسين هذا من حيه لنسمي الاشياء باسمائه
يا استاذ محمد الاقليات التي يتحدث عنها
الجماعه هم التجمعيين يعني هم انصار بن
علي في الاعلام في الثقافه في السينما
البرجوازيه رؤوس الاموال رجال الاعمال
السياسيون يعني ثوار ما بعد الثوره كل
هؤلاء يريدون تعطيل المسار الانتخابي لانه
ليس في صالحهم يريدون قلب البلاد والعوده
الى الى الخلف يعني مهما كانت الوطئ مهما
كان الدستور فانه لن يناسبهم هذه النقطه
النقطه الثانيه هو ان المشكله بالنسبه لي
ليست في النص المشكله في اليات تطبيق النص
لان يعني بيان 7 نوفمبر يعني نص جميل
وشاعري لكنه نعرف الى ماذا اسس الى مرحله
ديكتاتوريه يعني كبلت تونس وتونسيين يعني
وانت تعرف كيف كانت يعني الحياه السياسيه
والثقافيه في تونس ثم ايضا كتابه الدستور
الدستور التونسي حتى في زمن بجيبا كان
جميلا وشاعريه ينص على ان تونس لغتها
العربيه ودينها الاسلام لكن نعرف انه كانت
ان اليات تطبيق هذا النص هي اليات استئصال
بالدرجه الاولى لركائز الهويه وهي اللغه
العربيه والدين الاسلامي ومجموع القيم
الاصيله لتونس يعني تونس لديها تاريخ طويل
في كتابه الدساتير ليست هذه المشكله
المشكله كيف نهيئ مجتمعا ونخب واليات
وهيئات قادره على تفعيل هذا النص يعني ان
نخرج النص من الكتابه من الدلاله الى
الواقع المرئي نقطه اخيره استاذ محمد وهي
هيئات موازيه كان لا بد لها ان تبدا في
الاشتغال وهي هيئات موازيه لكتابه الدستور
هيئات هامه بالقضاء لتطهير القضاء او
اعاده تسكه القضاء ثم هيئه ثانيه للاعلام
وهيئه ثالثه للاعداد للانتخابات هته
الهيئات ما زالت الى اليوم معطله يعني
هناك هذا التردد الكبير والجميع الى ماذا
ينظر ينظر فقط الى الثوب المرئي من كل هذا
وهي الظاهره السلفيه نعم ايضا سيد هنيد هل
تعتقد بانها ستتمكن تونس في النهايه من
وضع حد لهذا ال الوضع الغير مستقر وان
تنصرف برايك في الاسابيع المقبله الى
تعميق الحوار حول موضوع الدستور واهم
القضايا المطروحه
فيه اعتقد ذلك ونحن نعول استاذ محمد على
الشعب التونس العظيم وليس غير يعني نعول
على الطبقات المسحوقه يعني على الطبقات ال
الصغرى النخب لا امل فيها لانها راس حربه
الثوره المضاده اليوم ولا استثني احدا
الحاكم والسلطه ومن هو في المعارضه هاته
من ناحيه من الناحيه الثانيه اعتقد انه لو
يوجد حوار وطني وينتهي الصراع على الكراسي
والصراع على المناصب والصراع على هته
الكعكه اليوم بسبب هته الثوره اليتيمه
فنستطيع ان ننتقل فعلا الى مجتمع ديمقراطي
خاصه انها فرصه تاريخيه لتونس لن تعود
الينا حتى بعد 1000 سنه اليوم يعني ان لم
ننجح اليوم في الانتقال نحو مجتمع
ديمقراطي مجتمع قانون مجتمع عداله مجتمع
يعترف بالاخر ويعترف بحق الاخر في التعبير
وفي الاعتقاد وفي اللباس وفي كل شيء فان
ذلك سيؤسس بدل ذلك اما لتدخل اطراف اجنبيه
او الى صراع دموي على نموذج الجزائري او
ان نعود الى شكل جديد من اشكال الاستبداد
نخسر معه الثوره والثوار ودماء الشهداء
شكرا جزيلا لك سيد محمد هنيد استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه السربون كنت معنا
من باريس شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من العاصمه
التونسيه الكاتب والاكاديمي محمد الحداد
بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج وراء الخبر
دمتم في رعايه الله والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء